lorsque vous roulez dans le centreville
de Dijon c'est un obstacle auquel vous
êtes souvent
confronté la voiture moins libre de
circuler qu'il y a 40 ans car
souvenez-vous dans les années 80 Dijon
ressemblit à ça nous sommes ici Place
d'Arc il y avait des autobus sur toute
la rue de la Liberté et des voitures
garées partout en épis tout le partout
sur cette place c'était des
voitures l'hypercentre de Dijon c'est
désormais des artères totalement
piétonne et des voitures renvoyées vers
les 7000 places du centreville et ces h
parkings souterrains aujourd'hui c'est
nettement mieux on peut on peut se
déplacer à pied enfin moi je suis
piétonne donc ça va c'est agréable à
vivre il y a pas de souci de voiture ou
on est sûr on est on est bien quoi ce
soit piéton d'accord mais mais je trouve
quand même qu'il nous manque déjà des
bans pour s'asseoir là c'est une patine
noire quand il
pleut favoriser les piétons mais aussi
embellir l'hypercentre c'était la
volonté de la Ville de Dijon une
révolution pavé en main qui a débuté
dans les années 2000 comme ici place de
la Libération réhabilité en 2006 pour 5
millions et demi
d'euros quand on piétonise une ville
c'est pour apaiser bien sûr de FL moins
de circulation moins de pollution moins
de nuisance sonore également et puis que
ce soit plus agréable de venir en ville
aussi bien pour les riverins que pour
les touristes apaiser la population
réduire la pollution en centreville pour
les associations écologiste la mission
est réussie mais elle dénonce tout de
même le manque d'arbre et de verdure au
niveau végétalisation oui c'est hyper
minéral on voit il y a quelques arbres
de planté mais pour avoir des buissons
trouver des solutions dans d'autes
villes ils ont mis au pied
des fait des petits trous pour que de la
glcine ou autre pousse a certains
endroits où on peut pas planter le
rappelle souvent par exemple ici on ne
peut pas la place est minérale en plus
on a beaucoup de réseaux au niveau du
centrreville mais vous avez pu voir
qu'on met quand même des AR puon en a
place des Cordeliers place jemass après
la place de la Libération plusieurs axes
sont progressivement piétonisé comme la
rue de la Liberté ù 800 bus passés
chaque jour avant 2012 2,8 million
d'euros sont investis dans le chantier
depuis l'affluence a explosé avec 170000
passant chaque semaine et une activité
commerçante en hausse les professionnels
du secteur sont satisfaits mais
défendent une piétonnisation mesurée si
vous voulez attirer du monde en temps
normal on va dire il faut que la ville
soit accessible il faut que le centre
ville soit accessible il faut que le
centreville puisse offrir des places de
parking soit en ouvrage soit en surface
mais il faut un ensemble pour que le
commerce fonctionne et trop de
piétonisation et bien peut à un certain
moment nuire à
l'attractivité le centreville de Dijon
c'est 1400 commerces dans celui de
maximeoup les vacan il s'est installé il
y a quelques mois séduit par un secteur
totalement piéton chaque semaine 250
achats sont réalisés dans sa boutique de
manga plus vous avez de passage plus
vous es visibilité et plus Bou il va se
mettre en place donc ouais c'est un
c'est un argument indispensable en 2024
d'autres secteurs du centre-ville seront
Romagné l'embellissement de la rue mange
et de la place bossué est déjà annoncé
un projet à 5 millions d'euros